[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number 200 and
something or other it is so 200 and
something it's hard to believe that it's
200 and something and it's 2020
something it is 202 something I I'm
actually reasonably confident it's 2024
and you know how uh I know that no I do
not cuz shit's especially bananas yeah
already and it's only just begun it is
in the excellent phrase of my oldest and
dearest friend looking to be a
particularly banana pants year banana
pants that's better banana pants that's
uh for a wider audience um yep yeah so
it is the 200 something or other episode
207 207 and I have no idea if it's Prime
but I think it might be I didn't look
into it I kind of think it's not but I
didn't look into it but Zach's goingon
to figure it out for us yeah all right
so if any of y'all out there have
factors other than 1 and 207 we're up to
find out about not prime but I'm not
sure what okay apparently not prime it
just doesn't feel Prime to me all right
that is a case of misinformation an
honest error I did not intend to mislead
anybody and it was not a truth that I
was using to undermine people's trust in
government so it's not mal information
um it was just a simple error yeah I'm
wondering if uh attributing Prime to to
nonprime numbers could ever actually
help a person become suspicious of their
government I don't know so other factors
1 and 207 3 9 23 and 69 oh boy so Not
only was I wrong I was really very wrong
there's quite a few factors yeah yeah
yeah well here we are you are I am uh Dr
Brett Weinstein I remain Dr Brett
Weinstein and will for some time to come
I think yes yes and you are Dr Heather
Hing I am will remain so um hey join us
on Rumble that's where we are streaming
too uh we'll be lots of places uh after
after that but join us on Rumble also
please join us on locals after this
episode uh this time we're going to
switch up how we do our q&as we're going
to do uh few of them uh but we are going
to do them on locals only and uh on for
now the second episode of the month
which is this one and we're going to be
taking questions through the chat which
we've never done before we can't see the
chat during the live streams um but
we're going to do we're going to try
that this time so come over hop over on
to locals join us there um there's a
watch party going on now and then for
the and I will actually be able to see
the chat and bring your banana pants
leave your banana pants at home but wear
some other kind of pants bring your
banana wine if you have it but leave the
banana pants at home I know that's good
stuff I remember it well it is um so um
yeah that's that's basically also you
know there's always if you're looking
for evidence of banana pants you can go
over to our store at Darkhorse store.org
and find things about fizer and um scops
and blueberries which are not banana
pants at all and Goliath and Goliath
Goliath is memorialized yes at the store
yeah so we'll talk more about other ways
to find us and uh and support us and
such at the end uh but we will start
today's episode as we always do with our
three carefully chosen sponsors uh know
that if we are reading ads uh for
sponsors as we do three of them at the
top of every show it's because we
actually truly stand behind these
products or Services uh we do not accept
sponsors um who make things or provide
services that we do not stand by with
that said our first sponsor this week is
brand new to us it's a new year we've
got a few new sponsors it's pretty
exciting and this one is Van man we are
so excited to be sponsored by them what
if you could take an animal-based diet
approach I'm going to try that again
what if you could take an animal-based
diet approach to your skin care to your
toothpaste to your deodorant van man
facilitates you doing just that and
every single one of their products that
we have tried is phenomenal the vanman
company has a plethora of amazing
products including the one they are
probably best known for Tallow and honey
balm it's a miracle balm that works on
everything from anti-aging to athletes
foot and it's totally edible I don't
really recommend that but they're better
things to eat than you know than balm
that you might put on your face but uh
you could eat it uh which is one of the
signature features of Van man's products
that they make their they make what they
make with entirely uh food grade edible
products um that said most things you
want to eat uh don't really belong on
your face and vice versa
however um there are things in here that
you would want to eat just probably not
in this particular configuration vanman
then stepped it up even further with
their bison Tallow on honey balm it is
out of this world they've got versions
with and without essential oils and both
have Tallow from 100% grass-fed bison
bison are fairly lean so their fat is
particularly
nutrient-dense Manuka Honey which is
considerable antibacterial properties
organic royal jelly which is what the
hive produces for queen bees to eat
exclusively and organic cold pressed
olive oil from handpicked olives in
Greece so you could see you could eat
all of that stuff and you probably have
eaten all of those things if you are in
any way like us just not in this
particular form I recommend this goes on
the outside you can eat the things
individually to put on the inside so van
man's bison Tallow and honey balm is
fantastic smooth Rich decadent you don't
need much so it goes a long way and Van
man also has both Tallow based deodorant
and sunblock featuring all edible
ingredients get 10% off your first order
when you go to Van man's
comp.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse that's van man's company VN M
ANS c m p n
y.com Darkhorse to get 10% off your
first order you won't be
sorry awesome no it it is awesome I'm
stuck a little bit on honey bomb which
is such a an awesome combination of
syllables that I just honey bomb honey
bomb yeah exactly exactly um yeah it's
like we bomb spelled differently it
could even work and you just end up kind
of sticky right either way really yeah
it's it's like a a charm offensive a
honey bomb you know totally this this
stuff is great this T and honey balb
both in the original beef version and
the Bison version they're they're
remarkable okay speaking of things to
eat Sundays is our next sponsor this
isd's all-time favorite it's one of our
favorites too uh it is dog food uh and
the reason it's one of our fav is
because when you make your dog this
happy while giving her amazing food
that's good for her what's not to be
thrilled about so Sundays as longtime
listeners will know makes dry dog food
but it's not your usual dry dog food
this is no standard issue burnt kibble
the standard high-end burnt kibble that
we were feeding Maddie seemed to please
her just fine she's a labrador Labs will
basically eat anything but it turns out
that Maddie does discriminate she loves
the food that Sundays makes seriously
loves it if we run out of Sundays and
give her the previous highend kibble
instead she is clearly disappointed we
should be giving her Sundays she knows
it and we know it not only is Sunday's
madd's favorite it is also far better
for her than that standard burnt kibble
that comprises most dried dog food
sundas is the only human grade air dried
dog food air drying combines the best of
cooked and raw approaches like raw air
drying preserves nutrients and tastes
better than the high heat methods better
than raw though Sunday's unique air
drying process includes a kill step
which kills pathogens so unlike
freeze-dried raw or frozen raw dog foods
there is no food safety or handling risk
with Sundays and Sundays has no
artificial binders synthetic additives
or other garbage all of Sunday's
ingredients are easy to pronounce and
healthy for dogs to eat Sundays is an
amazing way to feed your dog there's no
fridge no prep no cleanup no wet dog
food smells it's a total pleasure for
the human interacting with it which is a
bonus in a blind taste test Sunday's out
performed leading competitors
420 and our own little anecdote Maddie
or Labrador not so little but little
enough supports that result she bounces
and Spins and leaps in anticipation of a
bowl of Sundays way more than for her
previous food do you want to make your
dog happy with her diet and keep her
healthy try Sundays we've got a special
deal for our listeners receive 35% off
your first order go to Sundays 4dogs
Darkhorse or use code Darkhorse at
checkout that's s n dys f r
dogs.com Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you're feeding your
dog not only that but in some sort of
mini collapse scenario if you ended up
having to share your dogs food you would
be so glad it's Sundays uh I speak from
experience I mean not from the mini
apocalypse experience but from the uh
having tried it and it's good and not
also from getting down on the ground and
eating from her Bowl which is gross oh
also undignified I mean just really bad
that doesn't necessarily stop
you days that's true that is true but I
mean that was more dignified than you
would you would imagine yeah much better
much more dignified I me it was a little
badass at some level right and I mean
we're only taking your word for it I
guess that's true yeah I didn't see it
true well I might have to repeat it you
might on camera even all right all right
I I'm willing but here we go I mean I
have not tasted it but it looks edible
it is yeah it is edible all right our
final sponsor this week it will be no
surprise to you is MD hearing now MD
hearing does not make hearing ear doogs
but it does make hearing aids now we
have friends what hearing your dog yeah
it's good I think so yeah I don't I
think there's a it's clearly an open
niche in the market it's a thought on
thk but now thousands of people have th
it yeah which I think is
progress and now they're wishing that
they didn't have their hearing ear dogs
turned on so they didn't have to think
thunk totally but if you had a hearing
in your dog I know what you should feed
it okay back to the ant um we have
friends and family who have hearing loss
there's a good chance that you do too
while we don't have need for hearing
aids ourselves we have good a good
friend who does we asked her to assess
MD hearing's newest product carefully
and honestly her testimonial is at the
end of this ad MD hearing makes
highquality simple effective hearing
aids for a a tiny fraction of what most
hearing aids cost helping bring audio
Clarity and capacity to people who might
not otherwise be able to afford it MD
hearing was founded by an ENT surgeon
who made it his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone could
afford MD hearing is an FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aid that costs a
fraction of what typical hearing aids
cost MD hearings brand new XS model
costs over 90% less than Clinic hearing
aids you don't need a prescription which
also means there's no middleman here's
the newest testimonial from our friend
who has substantial hearing loss and who
relies on hearing aids we asked her to
try MD hearing's newest product and this
is what she said MD hearing aids new Neo
XS hearing aids are powerful energy
efficient and Tiny they come with
settings for quiet social noisy and
restaurant situations the battery life
is over 18 hours with a short recharge
time the restaurant setting actually
works better than the restaurant
settings on my far more expensive pair
amplifying sound with SE uh within
several feet of me muffling sound in the
rest of the environment wow that sounds
good that was me editorializing back to
her quote I also tested them in a room
with white with a white noise generator
in Discord voice chat on on phone calls
with and without speaker as with the
previous sets I've tested the only sign
significant difference between these and
my usual set hearing aids that cost
about 12 times as much is smartphone
integration with app control but that
sing with that single exception MD
hearing aid is making all the hearing
functionality for for very expensive
hearing aids accessible to everyone end
testimonial so if you want MD hearing
aid smallest hearing aid ever go to shop
MD hearing.com and use promo code
Darkhorse to get their new
$397 when you buy a pair offer that's s
h o p MD h e a r i n g.com and use the
promo code Darkhorse to get their new
$397 when you buy a pair
offer all
right you know reading something that
you've never read before is always a bit
of an adventure with me but you know I
got through it mhm yeah you did you
did uh so we got a couple of
uh big broad topics
uh today do you want to start sure why
not all right all right um I just
promise we'll get to fats later whoa
yeah yeah so totally FS yeah um I mean
yes we will get there soon enough first
what you're going to talk about is the
strange aftermath of my discussion with
Tucker Carlson about
primarily uh the mechanism of vaccine
damage
and the who pandemic preparedness plan
that is currently hurtling towards a
planet near
you um the one that you are on yes in
fact that very planet is uh is
threatening to be uh tyrannized by the
World Health Organization um under this
new preparedness plan which will be
voted on by the member nations in May of
2024 yep yeah we we talked about the
hoop plan a couple months back on
Darkhorse um but I should say that uh we
didn't know that your Tucker interview
was coming out uh this week we would
have said something um in fact we've
heard from a few viewers hey you didn't
mention this um so you had recorded this
not too long ago but um um but not this
week and um so it came at least came as
a surprise to me that it came out and um
and it's fantastic and it has mostly
garnered um you know fantastic responses
and has been has been watched far and
wide like something something more than
like 6 million views six million views
in three days I don't know what what
it's at now but uh anyway it reached a
lot of people and there was a lot of
very good feedback um from all sorts of
folks who reached out having seen it um
both people that we know well and people
we don't who said that they had thought
it had encapsulated these issues
extremely well and that it had it had
woken some people up to specifically the
danger in the who document which you
know as we know is very difficult to
describe it is intentionally difficult
to make clear the hazard to civil
liberties that this document or pair of
documents um
poses because it's you know it's
designed to be boring and it's designed
to seem remote and basically uh like
somebody else's problem not very
important because if there's anything
bad in it of course your nation would
never let that um affect you that's why
we have experts to protect us from
problems like that right um and in fact
you know one of the things in the
interview Tucker sprung a clip of Tedros
talking about the claim that this was a
threat to sovereignty and um so I had
never heard this he's responding to the
claim which he says is on social media
and in podcast right right um he's
probably responding to us and a few
others and John Campbell who right um um
and he says that's just wrong right now
what I you know but we I mean read the
document talked extensively about the
document and it clearly is yeah well
what I said in on Tucker's program was
that Tedros was just lying and of course
what he said was tantamount to a lie but
on Rel listening to it I now see
something more in what Tedros said which
is this is not a violation of
sovereignty and then he implies the
reason it is not a violation of
sovereignty is because your nations in
which you have nominally elected people
to govern you will have signed on to it
so he is effectively acknowledging that
they are going to override your
sovereignty but says that that's all
within sovereignty because you agreed to
it when will you have agreed to it well
you were supposed to not notice that it
was happening and then your government
was supposed to agree to it in May and
then the um who was going to declare
some emergency and suddenly things that
you were never asked about were going to
show up on your doorstep it's like he's
making a claim of a kind of meta
representative democracy and which uh
your government is who you actually
elected even though it's now you know
for most of us a couple of levels deep
of representative democracy and they are
then using that proxy and saying okay
now you get like the who gets to
actually do our B do its bidding on our
behalf because you voted for us well
there are two things that are relevant
here one of them is uh you and I
sometimes reference the beginning of the
hitchhiker Guide to the Galaxy in which
there is a
parallel uh set of disasters happening
at two very different scales uh Arthur
Dent's house is being knocked down by
some local uh Construction Group to put
through a highway and his knowledge that
his house was to be knocked down was
somehow bureaucratically buried so that
he didn't quite notice that it was
happening till he
notices uh something out his window as
he's brushing his teeth and it begins to
Dawn on him yellow there's something out
there it's a bulldozzer and at the exact
moment that they're about to knock down
his house a hyperspace bypass is
scheduled to be put right through where
the Earth is and so the Earth is going
to be destroyed by the vogans and
there's some back and forth somebody on
Earth manages to send a message back to
the vogan saying you can't destroy the
Earth to put in a bypass and the vogans
say well the paperwork that was supposed
to allow you to complain about this has
been on
file the right time to complain is
passed there was plenty of opportunity
it was in the basement and yes the
stairs were missing and it was flooded
and there were crocodiles and it was in
a locked cabinet that was Rusty and
probably would have given you tetanus if
you gotten near it and all this but
there was an opportunity yeah don't say
you didn't have the right to challenge
this and you know now that time has
passed so anyway Tedros is effec Right
Tedros is effectively invoking this
defense that some document that you
barely know is happening has moved
through some channels that you're barely
aware exist that is going to result in
all of your freedoms disappearing but
the point is you can't say you didn't
have the right to object through your
representatives um now of course as we
do object they come back with that
ridiculous uh response but the other
thing that's relevant is a provision in
the law which you know I'm no lawyer I'm
a biologist but there is a provision in
the law that you can't sign away your
constitutional rights right you actually
just don't have the legal right to do it
it you can't decide to enslave yourself
um to somebody else right but they can
can the government decide for you no it
can't but the point is if if if Tedros
is saying that well you have the right
to elect representatives and they have
the right to object to the loss of your
sovereignty the answer is they don't
have any say over my sovereignty to
begin with right my constitutional
rights are what they are they don't have
the right to get rid of those things so
what the hell are you talking about
Tedros right that's that's garbage from
one end to the other but anyway let's
put that
aside so this interview this discussion
between me and Tucker comes out I should
say that the history of this discussion
works as
follows um we caught on I think somewhat
late to the fact that this who thing was
happening and as soon as we looked into
it it alarmed us tremendously right we
you know it was easy to ignore it and
then as soon as you look at it it's like
oh my God God what are they
contemplating as soon as we had figured
out what it was I reached out to Tucker
and I said do you know about this and he
said a little and he described what he
thought and I said well you're not going
to believe this and I told him what we
had come to understand and he said would
you be interested in coming to talk
about it and I said absolutely so that's
why the thing
happened but when it came out in
addition to all of the
um praise and the uh reports that people
had been alerted to something that they
hadn't been aware of there was a
tremendous amount of push back from
people um most of whom I'd never heard
of but it was amazing there was like
this whole layer of covid dissidents who
were enraged by this thing
and let's just say I think that the fact
of this is actually useful
because as much as it is very unpleasant
to face an enraged mob accusing you of
all sorts of things um it does allow us
to
see a
vulnerability in what should be the
protective layer that prevents
tyrannical things from happening and I
would claim that multiple things and in
fact I put out a tweet to this effect I
believe multiple things are contributing
to this one
dissidents by their very nature tend to
be lone
wolves and lone wolves tend not to be
very good at teaming up now even my use
of the word team in this discussion with
Tucker enraged people right so what I
said and this was clipped by some people
in broadcast was that Goliath had made a
terrible error and Goliath's terrible
error was to pick on all of the IND
independent thinkers and drive them out
of the institutions and so what I said
is that glias screwed up because by
driving out everybody who can think from
the institutions and what I should have
said is he drove out everybody who has
principles and insight and courage right
he just swept the institutions of those
people by doing that he created the
Dream Team right we're outgunned but we
have all of the people that you would
want to fight back against Goliath and
that was a fatal error on Goliath's part
wow did that piss some people off and
they're pissed off for a couple of
reasons go ahead um I am not as online
as as you are and um I have seen some of
what's going on but not a lot and one of
the things that I wonder and I and I
don't want to derail you here but um it
looks to me like some number of these
people aren't people oh no doubt so you
know I'm I'm left with um a decided
question about to what degree you know
there are now real people who are
chiming in but if if The Originators
were none of them real people or you
know or if they were paid um by
something else that is not them and that
is not obvious uh then this discussion
means something very very different yes
and the question is what do you do when
you can't you know clearly some of these
people are real we even know some of
them yeah
um very likely some of them are not real
and that you know you would imagine that
Goliath having been thoroughly
embarrassed by the dissidents over the
course of covid and now presiding over
the wreckage of a narrative that the
public now sees through that Goliath
would love to create tensions in that
group of people so that they cannot
point in the same direction and in fact
of course this would be happening as the
World Health Organization is gearing up
its own uh tyrannical rematch you would
want the people who fight tyranny to be
fighting each other right wouldn't that
be wouldn't that be great so yes I agree
there's an inorganic part of this and it
may be that the inorganic part seeds the
organic part right it may be that they
work in Synergy um but anyway a number
of things are going on and I think it is
worth understanding this
because I mean let's face it everything
is writing on our ability to repel
tyranny at not only the national level
but the international level we now know
that Co taught us this
so so my invoking the term Dream Team
triggered a bunch of people and yes
probably some Bots and sock puppets too
but it triggered a bunch of people to
react in a way I absolutely did not
anticipate right my saying hey Goliath
kicked out all of the people who can
think from the institutions and created
the Dream Team caused a bunch of people
to react as if I had said hey there's a
dream team and you're not on
it I didn't say anything about who's on
it they also said who are you to decide
who's on it I didn't say anything about
that either I just said you've got a
bunch of people who are now have the
same enemy who have also all of the
ability to think and that that's a good
thing I it's hard for me to imagine how
you even come to imagine that I'm trying
to uh impose some kind of narrative
discipline no I actually think that
disagreement is good and it's how we got
to understand as much as we did about
covid so well I mean I guess I guess
this is part of why I don't know why
it's worth engaging with people who
object to words like team I mean like
it's it's such such a lowlevel it's it's
not even an argument you know it's it's
just it's just pedantry um if I mean
that's not even the right that's that's
being too generous I don't even know
what it is it's it's it's it's like less
than kindergarten level taunting well so
first of all I I did engage one of these
people um or I tried to uh
and it sort of went superficially well
and then it didn't go well at all and I
don't know why that is but I I do want
to point out a couple things one the
name of this podcast is is Dark
Horse that's not an accident this
podcast is about people that you
wouldn't expect to find themselves at
the Forefront of an important fight or
whatever it is who show up out of
nowhere that is expected right to the
point that this podcast was named that
before there was ever a battle over Co
before there was a CO so the point is
the idea Le before we knew it well true
but the idea
that I or we are gunning for some
elitist version of events where only you
know people who are deemed worthy or on
the team fighting Goliath is
insane second thing
is how crazy is it I mean if we can
agree that tyranny is bad and we can
agree that whatever their likelihood of
success that the World Health
Organization is involved in gearing up
for tyranny that any dissident ought to
oppose then you have to ask yourself the
question how much good was done by six
million people becoming aware of this in
three days right whatever you your
problem with me might be you have to
just ask the question what is the net
effect of that level of exposure for a
uh an emerging tyrannical plan right and
if your point is this is simple look you
can challenge me on anything you want
you can say I'm wrong and by all means
if you are right and I'm wrong teach
right but be prepared that I may not be
saying what you think I'm saying to the
extent that I seem to be adhering to
some perspective that seems obviously
wrong to you maybe there's something you
haven't seen
yet and I I would also say that um you
know since we have we have have both
been professors and we have both seen um
hostility of various sorts uh either
because we were challenging uh
previously held beliefs by students or
they just didn't get what we were saying
or you know whatever or they or they
often they they were certain that they
had it right and we didn't right and you
know this has happened outside the
classroom as well for sure but it's
easier to talk about within a classroom
because everyone's been in a classroom
pretty
much very often very very very often
when a student would be certain that
that I or you were just being willfully
ignorant were were refusing to
understand the problem was
actually I you're not being clear I
can't I cannot track what it is that you
are saying and until until I can
understand what it is that you were
saying until you can put it in enough
different ways that I can understand it
then no I am not going to which was
often desired like you need to present
this other view you've not yet clarified
to me what the other view is there's no
presenting something until it is clear
what it is furthermore if we're talking
about science and we've got some
hypothesis on the table and you say I've
got an alternative hypothesis okay what
does it predict what you know what is
the predictive power of that alternative
hypothesis if you cannot answer that
question there there will be some Nuance
here but in general if you cannot answer
that question what does your purported
alternative hypothesis predict then it
is not an alternative hypothesis to this
thing that we're talking about and
therefore it doesn't deserve equal
stature on on the stage of discussing
hypothesis
so very often the people who are certain
certain a certainty is is a big red flag
um that if you are certain that you are
right now and you have always been right
how is that even possible
and if you are certain that you have the
alternative truth that no one else is
seeing figure out a better way to say it
then so that other people can understand
it because by and large when this when
that sort of thing happens it's actually
you you do not have the clarity in your
own head that you think you do and I'm
sorry but being able to communicate it
is part of knowing it and if you cannot
communicate it then you don't know it
and there's a good thing there's a good
possibility the thing that you think you
know you don't and there's nothing there
well and it's implied by what you're
saying but the next thing for you to do
is to return to the thinking stage if
what if you've got a model but it
doesn't have a
prediction you need to go back and
figure it out and what you discover in
pursuing the prediction is you will find
holes in what you thought you may find
the real model that you didn't see
because you hadn't given enough scrutiny
to look for the prediction so anyway
it's the the natural part of coming to a
a better understanding does involve
scrutinizing your own stuff and saying
you know if this is true why is it that
I don't have a prediction that sort of
thing but in any case the the reason I
say it is a good thing that this
happened is because the ability to
recognize this vulnerability it's not
like this is the first dissident
movement that's ever been uh torn apart
from the inside by infighting right
that's a regular feature of
disseny if you want the dissident to
beat the tyrants then we have to learn
what this is and frankly just you know
yes people will take it as condescending
but if you're involved in that then
level up come to understand where you
are if you understand better than the
people who are on the big
podcast okay refine your message figure
out how to get it in front of us and
we'll Elevate you but you know and I'm
not saying it's our job to do that but
the point is you're looking at an
organic movement of people you know you
and I are biology professors and
suddenly we're out here on the
internet discussing these things in
public because a in part it overlaps the
skill set that we developed as biology
professors in part because becoming
being a biology Professor was no longer
tenable at the point that the
administration of the college we worked
at turned the college over to frankly a
crazed mob that doesn't look so
different than the dissidents who are
currently claiming that they've been
mistreated so anyway I do think it is
valuable for all of us to recognize and
I want to I want to draw an important
distinction here the dissident movement
does not agree with itself about what
happened during covid it does not agree
with itself about the priorities going
forward there are large zones of
agreement and then there are large zones
of disagreement there no problem with
that that's how we get smarter right so
there's lots of people uh Dennis RC
court for example Nick Hudson these are
people with whom we have profound
disagreements but there's no disrespect
right there's no inability to sit across
the table from the person and say
actually here's why I think you have
that wrong and they can say here's why
you have it wrong and the point is
sooner or later these things resolve
over time that's the way it should work
and I believe I've met some of these
people and and not nearly as many as you
have um but I believe always um that
there is a shared interest in figuring
out what is right that I you know on the
question of SARS kov V2 the virus does
it
exist what I have seen suggest to me
that it does I don't want it to I'm not
invested in that as as as a reality as
an outcome what I want is to know if I
am wrong that I am wrong so that I can
reconsider all of the other things that
I think that may hinge on that basic
basic fundamental assumption that you
know that is what I want now we do we
will start to identify with some of our
beliefs right even things that we think
are factual we will start to to wear
them like they're they're part of who we
are and that is when it becomes
dangerous because it is harder to back
off um but I think you know one one of
the big one of the big issues that uh
people as you were saying you know in
the dissident Community disagree about
is whether or not there is actually a
virus and um I don't you know I I know
what I think based on what I have seen
and it's not important to me that I'm
right what's important to me is that I
discover what is right as soon as I can
now that doesn't mean that it you know
that's my priority because there are
there are an infinite number of things
about which people disagree and you know
we are constantly both you and I are
constantly being dragged into or people
are attempting to drag us into like oh
this thing I think you're wrong about
and therefore you have to focus here so
that you could clarify your
understanding there it's like you know
what I get to choose I get to choose
which of the things that I am thinking
about right now I'm going to focus on
and that allows me to have in the
background some things which yes may be
wrong but this is part of why I say that
certainty is one of the biggest problems
and that people who claim that they are
certain that the only way to be trusted
is to have been right first all along
you know what you're never going to be
right first all along and so if that's
really your precondition for trusting
someone you're going to be wrong yeah um
there's
also how can I say this one of the
things that I think is clearly true is
that I unfortunately I don't have a
synonym for the word game I know from
taking Game Theory very seriously that
the problem with game being in the title
of it is it suggests a kind of trivial
frivolous um aspect and you and I are
deadly serious about getting stuff right
and standing for what matters standing
for uh individual liberty sovereignty um
informed consent all of these
values the
ability to do that to to have a
discussion with somebody like Tucker or
Rogan um or to go on you know even worse
the worst of these are uh Network
programs where they give you three
minutes you know maybe they tell you
they give you five minutes and then you
know three minutes before they put you
on they say it's been cut to three
because somebody went long and you're
trying to keep your wits about you it's
very difficult but
the thing about um a
big a live to tape is the term for it
but where you have a discussion nobody's
going to edit it and you're trying to
get it right uh on camera that is much
more difficult than it looks that is a
skill that involves tensions between
many different values and one of those
values is getting it right right but
getting it right if you're not clear is
not valuable right and so there is a
tendency for people who have not you
know I would
say in any of these opportunities there
is some let's call it a value what could
be accomplished with that much time in
front of that audience right that is
always greater than what you set out to
accomplish right because you don't
understand
what might be accomplished so you've
already lost some value in going to what
you can imagine doing in front of that
audience in that amount of time and then
what you actually accomplish is even
less than that right it's difficult to
do the job and so my point would be if
you haven't faced that
situation then you may think you know
why didn't he say this right why didn't
he get to that and
it's really not a fair comparison you
need you need to understand that
actually the job is complex and um that
the tradeoffs are much greater than it
seems when you're just watching the
product of it well I think you mentioned
that um you know the mob at Evergreen
had analogies to to to this mob and
that's in part because mob is Mob but
it's in part also um because and you
know maybe this is in fact a relatively
or actually Universal feature of mobs or
of just you know the
the uninformed
angry uh which is that I I'm I'm
reminded of I believe it was Nancy ran
who first started pointing this out
about the woke mobs um not Evergreen in
particular but these these mobs you know
antifa like these mobs that just take
over and you know what took over
Portland in 2020 after George Floyd died
uh just night after night after night of
rampant destruction right
and what it was what became utterly
clear and in fact ultimately some of
them even said it was we just want to
destroy like that's what we do we just
want to destroy we have no
ability they did not say this but this
was you know ny's framing like they have
no ability to create yeah they they are
only destructive they only see something
which they have decided is not good and
instead of imagining a world which might
be better and working towards that they
say Must Destroy that which I see which
I do not like and this feels exactly the
same the same way and you know I see how
you could frame it as like no I know
what he should have said no because this
is actually a a creation a conversation
you know either a live stream or live to
tape is um is is a type of creation that
is unlike sitting in a bar with your
friends or being alone in front of your
computer writing uh and uh you know
could Perfection be obtained could you
you know could you could I could any of
us um go through something that we have
done and say ah I wish I had said that
better oh I wish I'd remembered I mean
any talk anyone's ever given right like
oh I forgot to do these two things y
right I do it every time every time
right no matter how good your visuals
are that are supposed to prompt you nope
you skip right over something like some
line that you had like you just you miss
it right so um it's it's very easy to be
an armchair critic but more to the point
it's very it's much easier it's always
easier to critique than to create always
and I think this is actually part of
what went wrong um in Academia as well
which was the sort of the elevation in
all of these new pseudo Fields plus the
Takeover of most of the social sciences
many of the humanities as well of
criticism and you know criticism is
Honorable and amazing and in a in a
great art class is absolutely necessary
and you need to expose your ideas
scientifically to criticism of of you
know of yourself of your peers of your
enemies everyone right but this idea of
critique as the thing that is done like
literary theory is often just critique
as opposed to generating new and the
fact is that's lazy and that's easy by
comparison and and that's what we've got
here there's a whole lot of critique and
um and you know no ability necessarily
to be like oh let let me do it let me
take an hour with Tucker and see how I
could do it like okay that's not
actually on offer but the fact is this
isn't a job that you know and uh and
critique is is is easy sing might is
easy well I'm going to separate two
things and I'm going to go back to an
analogy we've used before in ecology
ecology is a very Broken Field but it's
got a few uh useful tools one of them is
to distinction between what's called
exploitation competition and
interference competition exploitation
competition if you imagine that there
are if you're a hummingbird and there
are flowers that are putting out nectar
then you are in competition with
everything else that wants that nectar
and by exploiting the resource you leave
less of it for others but you're
not damaging others so that they can't
get to the resource right you are
competing by exploiting the resource at
a higher rate than they
are I think critique in this context if
somebody is angry at me because of
something I've said and they want to put
out stuff that shows why I've got it
wrong right then the point is there's a
space of attention of thoughts and they
may very well Eclipse me and that's to
the good and then my next move is I see
this thing and I think you know actually
yeah they have a point there actually
they don't have a point Point here I may
respond to that thing that makes us all
stronger and what it does that's most
important is it makes us most likely to
succeed in the important goal which is
defeating whatever it is that's moving
through the World Health Organization
claiming that our surrender of our
sovereignty is our own goddamn fault so
if you want to engage in competitive
behavior and critique is part of that by
all means do it and do it well the
better you do it the better off we are
on the other hand if what you're going
to do is go after people who are trying
to do the right thing people who are
behaving in an honorable fashion doing
the best they can trying to make things
better for us you are part of the
problem and that's interference
competition right that's poisoning the
soil so your competitors can't grow that
is not elevating anybody and what does
it do it absolutely makes it more likely
that the tyrants are going to do exactly
the stuff that you don't want them to do
that you claim is motivating your anger
at me um so y I should say we haven't
mentioned uh lockdown specifically yet
the reason the most concentrated
criticism that I am getting is on my
position relative to lockdowns and um I
feel stuck in this case because I know
what my position is and I know why it is
my position my position has changed
several times about lockdowns I can
articulate what it is today but the last
thing I want to do what I you know if
there's anybody who has had the advanced
training course in facing angry confused
mobs it's
me I know that if I do what these people
want right if I give them what they want
they will be enraged even further right
I'd make more demands and at some point
you will stop meeting the demands and
you will never apologize for that which
you did not
do these things I'm just saying in
general you will never apologize for
anything that you did not do legitimate
honorable apologies need to remain
legitimate and honorable and therefore
you do not make false apologies and a
mob that is not apologized to when it
demands one that uh makes demands uh
that you aced to and then makes more
demands that you stop a seeding to
because you realize it's an infinite
process and you can never win only you
say becomes more enraged I would just
add one thing to that which is you don't
apologize for stuff you didn't do and
you correct errors if the errors were
Honestly made you don't apologize for
errors you just say I got it wrong and
now this is my position and so the
demand for apology is out of place in
the first place because it presumes
things about motive that are just simply
false right it's it's the wrong
Paradigm um so do you w to yeah um it
just occurred to me when we were talking
today actually excuse me um that what 11
10 and a half months ago excuse
me I was I don't remember actually what
prompted exactly this piece in Natural
Selections you can show my screen here
um but I wrote a piece that was not
exhaustive at all but basically laying
out the points um that we have been
making on covid on Darkhorse uh from
from the beginning and a few of you know
a few errors especially early on and a a
bunch of not errors in which we were
right we were early we lost you know we
lost a lot right we were demonetized and
and
lost um lost people and such um but
demonetize I would I would point at has
become ever clearer the more uh time has
passed our channel was skyrocketing in
terms of uh uh
subscriptions at the point we were
demonetized that stopped instantly y so
not only Not only would we have easily
had uh Financial Independence very
quickly uh with that rate of growth but
the rate of growth was itself growing um
I mean with the money that was coming in
and the rate of growth was was high and
the capping of the size of the channel
has effect on all kinds of things
because when you publish a book when you
try to get advertisers to sign on
everything is scaled to how big is your
reach so um so these things matter so
yes we pay a high price but every so
often and this week it's uh your
interview with tiger Carlson um people
decide that becoming enraged is the
thing to do um and so I wrote this
apparently with the bad guys or don't
ask permission to speak and it got a lot
of a lot of positive engagement um and I
just well I'll read the first couple of
paragraphs here were you silent on the
question of viral Origins before John
Stewart and the United States Department
of energy told you that you were allowed
to think certain thoughts those thoughts
were dubbed conspiratorial and dangerous
and uncareful until they
weren't oh maybe it did come from a lab
after
all did it take Woody harelson on
Saturday Night Live to point out to you
that pharmaceutical companies are acting
as drug cartels and the media is in
their sway Financial incentives dri
Drive success in business and fiser is
nothing if not successful these
days huh maybe fizer wasn't the White
Knight we were told it was these last
three years too many of us have let
social coercion and fear Drive what we
say out loud and even what we think
we've outsourced our thinking to
self-described experts credentialed
well-dressed well spoken experts who
have been wrong disast disastrously so
over and over and over again fool me
once shame on you fool me twice shame on
me fool me three times four times 50
times 100 what the hell shame on all of
us who continue to fall for these
games uh I I read a little bit more here
actually we we need to be suspect of any
conclusion that arrives fully formed
especially if no questions are allowed
in response to pronouncements from the
government and health agencies get in
the habit of saying I'm not sure about
that it can open your mind and once your
mind is open all manner of wonderful
things can happen it may not keep you in
good stead with your social
GP my husband Brett Weinstein and I have
said a lot of things these last three
years that have angered people before
John Stewart or the department of energy
or Woody harelson had said anything
publicly we were publicly discussing
using the scientific tools at our
disposal the very real possibility is
that SARS k 2 was the product of gain of
function research and while its
foundations were borrowed from a bat the
final product came from a
lab the vaccines that were developed at
record speed and presented as the one
and only solution to the problem of the
pandemic specifically the MRNA products
are neither safe nor
effective many alternative treatments
for Co exist including but not limited
to repurpose drugs with extensive safety
records that are long out of patent such
as icin and hydroxy chloroquin
for this we have been vilified so let me
just say um and there's
more um I have a long bullet list of
various of our positions uh with links
to where we first talked about them as
far as I can find in our in our long
list of um Dark Horse episodes um since
May of 2020 here are a few of the other
things that Brett and I have got voiced
to these last three years conclusions
that we came to through observation
checking of our assumptions analysis and
reanalysis be careful though consider
these ideas and who knows what could
happen and I begin with what I see as
two of our big mistakes early in the
pandemic we thought that masks were
broadly effective we were wrong first we
spoke about the importance of masks and
as new evidence came in our position
changed we spoke about that
too we also thought that short early and
strong lockdowns had a chance of
stopping the spread of SARS k 2 we were
wrong about that I don't think lockdowns
could have worked in part because I
don't think sufficient worldwide
compliance was possible to stop the
spread and as much as I am disappointed
to have handed to have landed here I no
longer trust my government to borrow any
of my
freedoms so it goes on and on and on um
so maybe this is the point to talk about
uh what my current position is on
lockdowns and uh what I regret and what
I don't regret good my current position
first of all I do not believe that given
what SARS kovy to
is that there was any potential to
control certainly not control spread and
my focus has been actually driving the
pathogen to Extinction so the reason
that I will not just simply say
lockdowns could never conceivably work
under any circumstances against any
pathogen is that there remember I'm a
biologist here's what I'm focused
on a novel pathogen that were to Jump by
human Med meding or some other mechanism
into the human population from some
animal
source that therefore starts out at uh
some low level but has significant
virulence so I'm just painting a
scenario
here were there to be a novel pathogen
that leap into
people but had not yet become endemic to
humanity if one could drive it to
Extinction in that early phase the value
to humanity would be incalculably large
and I choose that that phrasing very
carefully the reason that it would be
incalculably large is that the
alternative of allowing it to run its
course and become endemic is for it to
continue to inflict costs on humans for
as long as humans continue to exist so
there is a a value to taking a pathogen
that there is still the potential to
drive it extinct and doing so rather
than running out the clock and letting
it become endemic so you can disagree
with me that that's something to be
worth focusing on but you can't disagree
with me that if one had the ability to
drive a new human pathogen to Extinction
that the value of doing so would be very
high and would be worth a significant
small a significant but small cost and
that is why I have said short intense
lockdowns however so there's that I do
not believe there is a government on
Earth today at least not at any large
scale whether a city government could
have some uh alternative scenario I
don't know but the idea that there's a
national government or an international
body on Earth today that could be
trusted with this kind of power is
preposterous nor do I expect to live to
see a government worthy of trust in this
regard so going forward I would oppose
any lockdown because I regard the people
who would be issuing uh such an order to
be illegitimate and very likely up to no
good but um the point is when I have
presented this idea I have said it as a
brief intense lockdown accompanied by
High quality testing and the idea is in
this
scenario a pathogen that spread and
burned itself out in some short period
of time and where in those rare cases
where for some reason it was able to
bounce around for long enough to escape
that period of weeks you would be able
to find it with the testing that would
allow in principle some uh properly
organized body to figure out how to
drive a pathogen to Extinction and
benefit Humanity tremendously again I
would oppose any lockdown that came uh
with from normal Earth governments at
the moment but I do not rule out the
possibility that in the future you could
face a pathogen that it would be worth
doing what's more I would point this out
the reason so the folks who are
attacking me have been very focused on
the idea that I in some hypothetical
scenario favor
something like an intense lockdown and
they've been very avoidant of why that
is paired with short duration in other
words if you're looking to paint me as a
villain you would focus on the one thing
and you would ignore the other which
they have done they have also ignored
the fact that I've said that absent good
testing this would be pointless I'm not
arguing that this is a useful way to
control the spread of a pathogen I'm
arguing that in the brief period before
something becomes endemic that it could
be used to drive a pathogen to
Extinction and that the disproportionate
value of preventing a pathogen from
becoming endemic is of a different sort
and I would argue that reasonable people
all understand that although civil
liberties are sacran and should be that
there are circumstances in which you
make a compromise so for example no
reasonable person would argue that if
you have an active shooter and they are
wandering through a school that locking
down the ation of that school is a
violation of their civil liberties that
we ought to complain about right giving
the police the ability to have access to
the shooter and keeping people safe from
the shooter is a perfectly reasonable uh
reason to have a lockdown is it an
abridgment of people's civil liberties
you bet it is but we all understand why
right um likewise if you presumably had
somebody you know if somebody released
small poox from one of the places where
it is maintained uh under lock and key
and some person had small small pox and
they were wandering around a hospital
would it make sense to lock down the
population of the hospital so that they
didn't contact the person with small pox
yes it would so the only reason I'm
pointing this out is that even though
civil liberties are sacran we can all
understand that there are circumstances
in which it makes sense to um prioritize
something else briefly and that is an
extension of the argument that I've been
making that said I am not favoring
lockdowns I do not believe they were
ever appropriate for SARS K2 nor was the
rationale that we were given for those
lockdowns the one that I'm pointing to
the rationale we were given was some
nonsense about flattening the curve and
preventing the hospitals from being
flooded which was apparently
from the get-go the hospitals were
largely empty so I'm not defending
anything like lockdowns that we had and
I'm not advocating that we should leave
the door open to them in the future
because there's no government that could
be trusted with it but is there a reason
to leave the concept open for some
future scenario that we cannot imagine
yes there
is good okay um
oh to your point about um how much of
this is
organic uh I do think we need to ask
this question even the people who are
actually dissidents and who are actually
in raged of their own accord they have
to ask themselves how much are they
being induced to to see a world that
isn't in order to keep us back on our
heels or whatever it is and I I wanted
to point to a couple things and it's and
it's just it's more it's more energizing
when you feel like you've got a lot of
people who are of the same mind oh this
is It's why mobs are what they are and I
guess something I didn't say when you
first introduced the idea that this um
when you were first talking about the
nature of this mob is there's something
mob mentality is uh low quality it's
amydala driven right yeah it's not your
highest mental centers um doing their
best to figure out what's going on it's
you de individuating and becoming part
of some and it's not a a thinking
careful thing
right you felt small before now you
don't feel small and that is a source of
power for people right they are tapping
into a feeling of a source of power
where all of these AG grieved people
have pointed at the same enemy and
ironically enough that enemy is me right
now uh a friend pointed out the
relevance of the work of Renee Gerard to
this situation which I'm surprised I
forgot to think of myself but Renee
Gerard um was a philosophical thinker
who generated a uh a model uh a
hypothesis about scapegoating that
effectively one of the galvanizing
forces in any group is the
identification of a scapegoat and the
targeting of them and this he uh
describes as basically the nucleating
event that causes witch hunting right
yeah SK good or witch either way yeah y
but anyway so it's very odd and
certainly ironic that I would be the
target of these people's ey but it's not
that surprising that they would find
some Target and you've been in the witch
seat before uh it's it's a place I seem
to find myself and and uh I will remind
people um that two days I believe before
Evergreen melted down I put on the board
for my students a model of witch hunting
um if I remember it correctly it was in
every such scenario there are a tiny
number of people who will instigate a
Witch Hunt there are a fair number of
people who will participate in in a
Witch Hunt there are a large number of
people who will say nothing and there
are a tiny number of people who will
oppose a Witch Hunt those are the
witches yep um so anyway it's there is a
reason that I end up in this situation
and um I guess I'm kind of proud of it
but let's uh you want to play that
little video clip so let me just say
that this is some I guess podcaster
never heard of him who showed up and his
stuff started being circulated against
between the people who were going after
me and I think it's just fascinating to
me what it is
so
[Music]
yeah for today lastly um we're going to
get into a little bit of uh contentious
territory here um I have been openly
critical of podcaster Brett Weinstein uh
I used to watch Brett's show a lot of
y'all might remember in the first
episode of of this podcast um I
specifically called out Brett for his
views espousing uh a Jew a genetic
genetic Jewish Supremacy let's say uh
this idea that that the Jewish people
are genetically Superior to everyone
else and More in inherently more
intelligent than everyone else um and
I've also been super uh vocal about my
you know um my issues with his coverage
of the co
response and it seems like some people
are starting to catch up with that um
this account on Twitter um Jessica
hawkett uh I I don't know her um I don't
know you know I don't know who she is or
whatever but um she recently posted this
clip of Brett on somebody's show uh I
guess this is Michael shellenberger um
who was a
report
so here's what's interesting
extraordinary yeah
he says that he's been critical of me
for arguing that uh Jews are genetically
Superior
now I know that I have never said this
because I know that I believe it's not
true which is something I have said and
this is not something about which you've
changed your mind no this is something
this is something I have been arguing
always known I have been arguing this
from long before I was in the public eye
the
unlikeliness of genetic superiority is I
believe a biologically important
argument and that anyway
so I don't know where he gets this or if
it's organic at all I know it's
inflammatory it's super inflammatory and
I mean I you just have to wonder you
know do they think you're someone else
are they just making it up out of whole
cloth well and you know there there's
going to be things I mean this is that's
too absurd right I mean you this is
actually a topic on which you have
talked many many times and have been
very clear every time and there's just
no ambiguity there are others who are
ambiguous because maybe they do actually
have cryptic beliefs they don't really
feel like saying yet and uh but that's
not you but that it does reveal though
how many such points could be made where
you're like God I don't know I don't
think that but do have more Nuance than
you might think and oh gosh what did
they what do they think I said like you
you they could cause a person to spin
not this one because this is too
obviously wrong right but there are so
many topics on which you can get people
spun up yeah but this one at this moment
in history this one is particularly
useful right right you have a Resurgence
in anti-Semitism you have a uh very
dangerous situation in the Middle East
continuing to unfold and so just sort of
introducing the idea that I Harbor this
belief and that he's been critical of me
so at the very best he is incredibly
sloppy and doesn't know what he's
talking about and uh has misunderstood
something about my belief or who I am or
whatever um but let's just say it
doesn't really matter because
nobody checked him nobody asked him for
receipts on that right it was just taken
to me oh yeah Brett sucks yeah here's
another one of the things he he's
terrible about right okay then he
doesn't even know enough about what he's
talking about to recognize that that's
my podcast not shellb Berger's podcast
so he's completely misunderstood the
context it's as if shellenberger is
asking me about this no I sat down with
shellenberger and had this conversation
so anyway it's extremely floppy yeah and
you're in a space that's not your own
but that's just because you were
traveling but it's yeah it's dark horse
yeah yeah but the sloppiness is Extreme
and and again a a mob is not a careful
thinking entity it is a verificationist
entity it is an overfitting engine right
it is looking for confirmation of the
villainy of the thing it's targeted at
it's not looking for disconfirming
evidence that would CA you know how
often in this circumstance or any of
these witch hunts does somebody say
wait a minute that's a piece of evidence
I didn't know about maybe I shouldn't be
in this mob at all I'll be over there
while you guys are witch hunting because
I now know something is off right that's
not one of the features of these mobs
but here's the thing even in an actual
mob you were able to reach some people
and so the asynchronous virtual nature
of an online mob is even harder to
dissuade is even harder to dismantle
because when the actual mob came for you
you reached people and you you you ended
up talking to people and they ended up
having thoughts and questions that they
never imagined that they would
have it was real time you were face to
face and they were able to see and
perceive through all of the things we
don't have language for that you were
actually willing and interested in
engaging them and that what they were
bringing to you as their claims against
you were actually surprising to you that
these were not true right the things
that they said were true of you were not
true and you were surprised that anyone
thought that and that that actually goes
a ways
right there's no way to do that when
there's a bunch
of a bunch of people putting out content
constantly that's just full of and again
we have no idea is it lies is it
intentional it's wrong either way it's
wrong but it's much much harder to
actually take apart a mob when it is
both asynchronous and there is
no it's not meat space right there's
there's there's no actual ability to say
oh you're a real person and I can
actually distinguish things that you're
saying it's only language like okay so
it's video so we get to seear you're
moving a little bit but there's so much
less there's so much less of what the
actual signal of human engagement is
than when you are in person uh that's
absolutely correct um
there's
also
uh one of the tough things about our
position is that we have spent so much
time exploring our understanding of
things and having that understanding
evolve in real time uh that you know
it's impossible to know where the things
we've said are when they were said and
all of this and actually somebody that
could you put up the tweet somebody was
responding and found some timestamps in
a June of
20120 uh Rogan
discussion um that I did so here
um somebody came to my defense and
pointed out that in June of
2020 uh on the JRE
podcast at 1548 I said in my opinion we
should have locked down severely for 6
weeks or something and then the quote
continues and then at
20220 I said we should be outdoors we
should not be locking down those
environments at all so if you were
paying this much attention then you
understood that there was a deeper model
at work and in fact you know you and I
never get credit for this but one of I
think the stronger early things that you
and when I did was come up with a model
of um the effective volume of a space as
it affected
transmissibility and the point was
outdoor spaces as much as it is
surprising and conspicuous outdoor
spaces were effectively completely
incapable of allowing the virus to
transmit yep and therefore the Locking
of them down was an absurdity and you
and I were shouting from the rooftop
tops there's no way you should be
locking down beaches and state parks you
should be encouraging people to go there
what's more in our our book the uh first
draft of it was finished as we emerged
from the jungle having completed that
draft and no but a couple months
later it as as lockdowns were hitting um
the first draft was being submitted in
March of 2020 okay the um Dum that was
written after we emerged from the jungle
when we heard about covid for the first
time so you and I uh went to Ecuador and
worked on the book and when we emerged
we learned about what was then called
novel Corona virus so the point is the
book was written without knowledge of
the fact that there was going to be this
pseudo emergency or whatever we added
something to the book and what we added
was a section which we have covered here
on Darkhorse and what it says is as a
thought experiment if human beings could
have agreed to stay Outdoors for two
weeks we could have driven SARS K2 from
the face of the Earth because it can't
apparently transmit Outdoors now I
worried a lot when we used to talk about
uh the fact that it did not appear to
transmit outside that evolutionarily it
would learn that trick sooner or later
you know I don't know if it has um there
is the weird fact of deer having shown
uh a high degree of infection I've never
understood this piece of evidence but
and it's been very hard to track to what
degree they are made ill like I don't I
don't I don't trust those data there's
something odd about it that a virus that
doesn't transmit between people Outdoors
should have reached uh a high level of
penetrance in a wild creature when did
that happen so anyway we don't know what
that means but but the point is
if your point is oh uh Brett or Brett
and Heather are pro- lockdown when you
and I were shouting about the fact that
we were being driven indoors which is
where the virus transmits and forbidden
to go outdoors and that that was an
absurdity at every level right you're
not seeing the full picture the mob
should be puzzling over the fact that
it's got some evidence yes I have said
that uh there are circumstances in which
a lockdown could make sense but then
we've also said a bunch of things that
are completely inconsistent and what's
more the interview in question is
targeted at derailing the tyrannical
capacity of the World Health
Organization to create Global lockdowns
so what the hell people wake
up fair enough um I'm remembering I was
just looking through my spreadsheet of
of our episodes where I don't you know I
don't have time stamps but I have I have
notes I can't remember I think it was
April of 2020 may have been may but I
think it was April um in which one of
the papers that I had run across
um you know all the research coming out
of China at that point I now don't know
what what all to make of it but this
paper seemed particularly well done and
uh it it purported to have looked at
some staggeringly large number of cases
of covid and um tracked basically where
uh where the point point of transmission
was and there was one and only one case
uh which could be uh could be attributed
to an outdoor transmission it was a guy
who was extremely sick hacking hacking
hacking right up next to his neighbor in
some contentious conversation maybe I've
made up contentious but in some
conversation that went on for a long
time in which he's up close and he's
hacking and um and that's the only one
and so that that was you know for me um
the moment I remember going like okay
and yet at the same time they're putting
danger tape up on children's playgrounds
yeah they've they've closed down the
schools they've closed down work and
they're locking families up alone
together and not giving the children
anything to do and you know this is
again one of these bullet points in this
Natural Selections piece keeping people
inside was a huge
error closing parks and beaches forest
and playgrounds was a mistake every
everyone should have been getting
outside as much as possible moving their
bodies with enthusiasm and abandoned
breathing in the air letting the sun
shine down upon their bare skins for
every reason for vitamin D reasons
psychological health reasons right so um
the yeah I mean
I I hate feeling defensive about this
point but do we make errors yes have we
been good about correcting them yes are
we lockdown Fanatics no
um and it it is uh very troubling that
this should now be caricatured um by the
very people who ought to be pointed at
the same enemy which is the World Health
Organization and whatever is driving it
to install these totalitarian measures
in advance of some yet to be declared
emergency that's the obvious enemy and
when people say what team are you
talking about um I'm talking about
whoever is willing to fight that thing
and if you want to fight independently
go for it if you want to interact with
other people who are fighting it that's
even better but don't tear people down
who are actually earnestly trying to
fend this off before it is sprung on us
in some future
context
um yeah maybe I'll just leave it there
there's lots of other stuff we could
show but I think I think we've more or
less covered it um the infighting is
destructive I think it was valuable to
have seen it in this circumstance where
uh we are not in the middle of an
unfolding emergency Let's uh Purge this
Instinct and get back to fighting the
Real Enemy as soon as
possible should we talk about fat of
course yeah okay um show my screen here
for a second here Zach uh I came AC
across this article and I think I was
pointed to it on Twitter and I don't
remember uh exactly the source I
apologize editorial on
nutrition chronic non-communicable
disease risks presented by lipid
oxidation products in fried foods so
we're going to explain this I'm not
there's a lot of technical stuff here
that I'm not going to go into but um I
will say this is published in uh
unexpectedly the hepatobilary surgery
and nutrition the Journal of
hepatobilary surgery and nutrition uh
and it's an editorial so already we're
in some strange territory and one of the
things that suggests to me is you know
either these people are you know they
have nothing to offer and they've just
managed to get some Fringe journal to
publish some thoughts on something
because there's lots of that that
happens or um they've got a very
important point to make and they've been
trying to make it through the normal
channels and no one is listening and so
they're trying trying some new stuff and
that is what I've come to understand
about these authors who have been
publishing for decades since the mid90s
on exactly this and again it's chronic
non-communicable disease risks presented
by lipid oxidation products in fried
foods so the particular the particular
thing that they're talking about is the
risks of frying okay not just eating fat
cold um but what happens to various
types of fats when you fry them and
specifically when you fry them um over
extended periods of time as we know that
for instance uh commercial kitchens like
fast food um will use the same
uh fryer vat vat yeah vat of fat for um
gosh I don't even know probably days
weeks I hope not one week is your one
week okay so um you know is there is
there a difference between fresh fat and
old fat is there a difference between
different kinds of fat in terms of what
kinds of products they produce in the
foods that you are frying that then you
are then
eating before and so these authors again
have been writing about this have been
doing research they are they are
academic researchers uh since the 90s
and no one appears to be listening and
so they've they've written this this
piece um but first maybe a little
background on types of fat uh because it
it's oh careful I need my screen here
um
uh let's see what did I want to show
okay um before yeah don't don't show my
screen here um we're talk they're
talking about saturated fats unsaturated
fats and uh somehow the world has
already caught into the fact that trans
fats aren't good for you so they're not
even they're not even looking at trans
fats particularly but um there are four
basic and and specifically they're
talking about fatty acids which I'm just
shortening to fats and so the acronyms
that you'll see in this paper which I'll
link
uh and in in general are um saturated
fatty
acids unsaturated F fatty acids of which
there are two types monounsaturated
fatty acids and polyunsaturated fatty
acids and then trans trans fats trans
fatty acids uh and basically the
saturated fatty acids are are typically
things like um you know fats that have a
high degree of saturated fat um are
solid at room temperature and they come
from animals things like butter and
Tarot and Tarot Tallow and lard and such
um and unsaturated fats monounsaturated
fats uh fats that are high in
monounsaturated fats tend to be things
like olive oil uh and uh macadamia oil
and um and others and then
polyunsaturated fats are the are the
seed oils basically uh and again all of
these fats have all of these types of
fatty acids in them um but the ratios
are very different between the types
types of fats so um you know anything
that you when people say vegetable oil
what they actually mean is seed oil and
that's like canola oil and safflower and
sunflower and grape seed and or grape
seed and canola are the same thing I
think is that right um no that is
different that's different um and then
and then trans fats don't occur in
nature basically that's something that
we've created and it's stuff like um
shortening um that is also solid at room
temperature and it was created probably
because people like their butter and
Bacon fat and um and they wanted
something spreadable that felt like
butter that they could use so I don't
think you've said saturated with what so
we're about okay we're we're about to go
there
um I wish I had a beautiful like
molecular biology or or nutrition uh
biology textbook version um I don't but
what I do have is a screenshot from a
con Academy course and I'll actually
link the Con Academy um just it's like
eight minutes and if it's it's it's
beautiful we're not going to show that
here but this 8 Minute Con Academy
lecture on on the difference between
fats is great and I'll just do a super
brief version here here's the screenshot
um from KH Academy in which uh the the
guy has um shown saturated fats
monounsaturated fats polyunsaturated
fats and trans fats so um this is
basically OEM short hand in which these
yellow yellow things are carbon chains
um carbon always makes four bonds uh and
when it's singly bonded to other carbons
it has two other positions um to to bond
to and a fully saturated fat has no
double bonds um with carbon there's no
there's no places where carbon is double
bonded like um like over there we've got
two lines um they're all single lines
and that means that every every carbon
is bonded to a carbon to the left a
carbon to the right and then two
hydrogens because hydrogen is what um is
sort of the the default position and
then to be a saturated fat it also um
and to be a fatty acid it also needs to
have some kind of one of one of these
oxygen-based groups as well we're not
going to go into that but a saturated
fat therefore is basically lines of of
carbons um that are singly bonded to
other carbons uh and have are full of as
many hydrogens as they could possibly
have that's what it's saturated with it
saturated with hydrogen and so they're
they're um linear and that's um this is
this is too simplistic but it's part of
why a saturated fat is going to be solid
at room temperature is that you
basically Jam a bunch of them in
together um that they pack in a way that
uh leaves them leaves the molecules
stable with respect to each other rather
than sliding around as they would in a
liquid exactly so a unsaturated fat is
one in which at least one in a
monounsaturated fat it's one in a
polyunsaturated fat it's more than one
at least one of the carbons is doubly
coal bonded um to to each other and that
means that that a carbon that has at one
side a single bonded carbon to it and
another side a double bonded carbon has
only one more position that it has
available uh and that's going to be a
hydrogen right there but that means that
there is for each for each double bonded
carbon in a unsaturated fat there are
two fewer hydrogens than there would be
if that was a single Bond maybe this
doesn't matter at all that's presumably
we could if they were if they were
acting in in in honesty and good faith
and actually trying to figure out what
was good for humans that's maybe what
the early food scientists thought maybe
it's um maybe it's not a problem at all
and in fact what we still have um in in
nutrition science today is being told
that unsaturated fats are way better for
you certainly than trans fats but even
than saturated fats so um that's a
monounsaturated fat and you can see it's
got this little kink in it it's got a
Bend because uh when you have a double
bonded uh carbon it causes the the chain
to Kink and it's just got one kink in it
for a monounsaturated fat it's got
multiple kinks in it for a
polyunsaturated fat and you can see the
more the more poly it is the more of
these double carbon bonds there are the
more Kinks and therefore the more uh
voluminous as is going to be and the
less tightly packed you're going to be
and the more likely you are to be liquid
at room temperature
uh so and again saturated fats is like
butter and Tallow and lard unsaturated
fats um things like olive oil and
polyunsaturated fats seed oils and then
trans fats um are and this we just
include this because it's included on
this screenshot here um in and this is
indeed the origin of um over in gender
ideology Lan CIS and trans language um
when you have a normal you know what
tends to occur in nature uh double bond
of the carbon um the hydrogens are
coming off the same side and the the
rest of the carbon chain is coming off
the same side but you can in the lab
switch that up and have uh the carbon
chain come off of say the top and then
it continues off the bottom and that's
called trans and that's why these are
called trans fats but what that does is
produce whenever you have these double
carbon uh bonds yes you don't have as
many hydrogens as you should if you were
fully saturated um but you don't have a
kink in the chain either and so you end
up with these relatively straight
relatively linear molecules that can be
packed together like
Crisco so that's sort of the very brief
description of what the difference is if
I can have my screen back here um
between um saturated fats and
unsaturated fats and um again I I did
not go into the history I don't know how
it is that we came to understand that
trans fats are bad for you because the
point you and I are growing up everyone
was cooking with prisco right shortening
was the thing and you know there were
people like I remember specifically my
dad it was like butter that's the thing
we're eating butter right um but you
know tubs of margarine and and crisco
like this this was we were being told
that this was good for us and now
somehow people know that's not true but
hold on people still are convinced that
the unsaturated fats are better for you
than the saturated fats because that is
what we are being told by everything
from the American Heart Association on
down the American Heart Association
which my I discovered this researching
something a few weeks ago yeah which was
apparently created actually to
legitimize uh seed oils right um and so
and you you've got
a you've got a kind of a pattern of what
always happens in this case you've got
some sort of food that is natural with
which our ancestors have an evolutionary
history and therefore we tend to be
pretty good at extracting the value out
of it breaking it down in a way that
doesn't make it toxic whatever whatever
it is it has some form factor right
butter fat and then you have an industry
that wants to deliver a product and it
has Laboratories that are capable of
addressing issues like um you know
you've
extracted some
plant oils you know corn oil and you
want to deliver it to people who are
eager for butter but they're not really
eager to pour corn oil on what they're
doing so it needs to take on a butter
form factor and so you can hydrogenate
it and you can get the form factor of
butter in something that the plant
created as a
liquid and to begin that though I'm
sorry if I missed it but you have to
have created skepticism of butter right
otherwise people just keep eating butter
right so this is really uh one of the
things I described in that Tucker
interview was the game of Pharma which
we have talked about on Darkhorse right
there is a nutritional game that is
exactly parallel older something that
would be profitable has to demonize some
other thing it has to demonize its
competitor oh that's not safe at all
right hydroxy chloroquin is not safe and
you know what else isn't safe butter
right so you got to demonize some
product and oh my God that's causing
heart attacks you know what you really
need you need some butter form factor
bread spread that uh is made from corn
oil right because they want to they have
an easy time growing corn the
profitability is high and so what
they've got to do is turn it into a
butter-like substance how do you do that
you throw hydrogens at it that's
wonderful except it's not yellow so you
can add some coloring to make it yellow
now it's very butter-like now you need a
advertising campaign ask ask your doctor
if margarine is right for you and uh
here we have it yeah this is a 1950s ad
for margarine that I used to use when I
taught about these things the smoothest
spread to put on bread you like
margarine of course you do it's good to
eat good for you and good for your
overworked food
budget and you like margarine yellow but
you get margarine
white why because of outworn laws that
place a federal tax of 10 cents per
pound on yellow margarin actually if the
law would allow it you could buy yellow
margin at no extra cost no wonder people
are riled up stirred up sorry it's tiny
fortunately wow I got to make this a
little bit bigger um oh fortunately
farseeing men in Congress are working to
see that you get margar and yellow the
way you want it give them your
wholehearted support remember the voice
of the people is the voice of the
lawmaker fight for the right to Yellow
margarine you've got to fight for your
right to Yellow margarine um right so
that's an actual ad guys that's an
actual ad from the 1950s from the
National Association of margarine
manufacturers of course it is so here's
the thing you and I grew up in the 70s
and 80s yep in households that had been
a victim of the margarine
sop um to to a greater and lesser degree
of Effectiveness I would say my family
was fully Hoodwinked your father wasn't
buying any of that crap because he was a
down toe guy who grew up on a farm and I
think growing up on a farm was the big
was the big thing right but anyway look
here's the here's the where the rubber
meets the road on this yeah it is you
and I have studied biology we have
arrived at a conclusion about what we
call hyper novelty that's largely the
subject matter of our
book there is no way that the process
the game of of big nutrition where they
identify a historical food they demonize
it they have a way of producing
something that's like it that will have
a much higher profit margin they create
it in the lab they adjust it and then
they run a s up to get people to accept
it there is no way that that ends up
healthy right right that ends up causing
health problems how many people have
died of uh pathologies that are
Downstream of uh
hydrogenated plant oils it's a huge
number we'll never know but it's a huge
number and the point is it was all
perfectly predictable right this article
has nothing to do with that this is not
hydrogenated plan else we're talking
about
here this is what I was raing my hand
about a little bit ago uh I was confused
because I looked up the ingredients in
of vegetable shortening and Marin it is
hydrogenated yes it is and that's not
what this article is about right so this
article is not about trans fats um this
is about unsaturated fats versus
saturated fats and specifically
saturated fats versus monounsaturated
fats versus polyunsaturated fats again
with the recognition that um so
polyunsaturated fats are they deriv from
a plant but they are really basically
not possible to be pressed without
modern techn technology and part of what
is wrong with the way that most of these
polyunsaturated fats um are produced is
the detergents and such that are that
are used to extract them which is
something that Zach has actually
informed us of quite a bit um all of
these fats everything from butter to
saff oil has some saturated fat some
monounsaturated fat and some
polyunsaturated fat but it's the ratio
that matters and so we can talk about
butter basically being a saturated fat
because it mostly is okay so um I'm
going to have you first just show the
figure um the original figure here from
from the paper and it's hard to
interpret it's typical sort of um you
know not very clearly labeled
unfortunately U scientific
uh oh that happens um um scientific
visualization um and I'm not going to go
into most of these details but I do I
did prepare better graphic based on the
same thing um but I just want to point
out before I go on uh that the two lines
on each of these graphs are about
um the total saturated and alpab beta
unsaturated alahh concentrations so
we're talking about toxic alahh um that
are being generated by the frying of
these fats okay so this is um just a
clearer version of same and I'm about to
tell you what
um uh a little bit more so figure one
the title is generation of cytotoxic and
genotoxic so that's cell- killing and
Gene destroying alic those are alahh
eyeses it's a particular kind of toxic
molecule lipid oxidation products that's
just like all of the oxidation products
that are generated in culinary frying
oils corn oil sunflower oil coconut oil
and butter with the four that they chose
subjected to laboratory simulated
shallow frying episodes so that's seems
that seems very like a lot of very fancy
talk um but basically they started at
time zero on the x-axis and go only
through 100 minutes which is a lot less
time than you're going to get and say a
fryer um that is being used for a weak
solid before you throw out the the fat
yeah this is the equivalent they are
testing effectively pan frying over a
short period of time M well short 100
100 minutes isn't that short well but
compared to a week y um and
uh and on on the Y AIS uh you have these
measures of toxicity so I'm not again
I'm not going to go into the chemistry
of exactly what those those measures are
but there there there these forms of
alahh and you can see just right off
right off the bat that corn oil and
sunflower oil uh have much higher rates
of the production of these cytotoxic and
genotoxic idic lipid oxidation products
uh then do coconut oil or butter and
it's even worse than you think because
check out the y axis on these things and
coconut oil and butter have y axes that
are twice that are half as short and so
they actually had to extend the Y AIS on
the on the high saturated fat fats in
order to get anything that was readable
which means that this is even worse than
it looks like and just to um just to
clarify so I keep on saying like
saturated fats monounsaturated fats
polyunsaturated fats these authors say
you know what all unsaturated fats are
are not equal the the less saturation or
the less unsaturation the better so
monounsaturated is actually better than
polyunsaturated fats and here are their
um ratios
of of saturated fatty acids to Mono
monounsaturated fatty acids to
polyunsaturated fatty acids in corn
oil 62% polyunsaturated fats in
sunflower oil 61% polyunsaturated fats
basically equivalent between corn oil
and sunflower oil in coconut oil
91% saturated fat amazing with 7% mono
unsaturated and only 2% polyunsaturated
and butter I'm a little confused about
this and a little bit of digging I I
couldn't figure out why the butter
numbers don't add to 100% uh it's not
100% fat because it's not oh because
it's protein protein yeah because it's
milk thank you that's G to that's going
to be it so I thought I thought this was
just about the fats but that's got to be
it that they're that they're looking at
the entire makeup of the butter so of
the portion you know given that butter
isn't 100% fat um I guess I'm not going
to be able to do the math in my head but
let's just say it's of of the fat no of
of the entire bit of butter 52% is uh is
saturated fatty acids 21%
monounsaturated fatty acids and 3.5%
polyunsaturated people can't see the
3.5% that's important highlight that
yeah so that's three yeah
polyunsaturated fats 3% 35 % in butter
yeah so that could that could look very
misleading um and you indeed see like
coconut oil I I I was surprised by the
coconut oil to butter comparison right I
we we cook with both um I love butter uh
and I would have thought the coconut oil
and butter were very similar to one
another just as corn oil and sunflower
oil are with regard to their um their
makeup of fats and uh and and no
actually coconut oil has way higher
saturated fatty acid content um and it
generates far less citotoxic and
genotoxic lipid oxidation products when
when food is fried in it at these
relatively short periods of time so I I
know you said it but can you describe
what the two different lines are it's a
mess uh so no basically if you want to
give me my screen back for a second SEC
so I can just make sure I go back to the
right thing okay you can read it now now
um
It's sigmoidal Time dependence of mean
plus or minus sem total saturated and
Alpha B Alpha Beta unsaturated alahh
concentrations red and blue respectively
so toal two different alahh yeah that's
what it is it's just it's it's just two
different alahh and um you know there's
a lot of all of these classes and I did
not go into the chemistry and figure out
what all the differences are and why it
is that you can divide them neatly into
two classes so um that's why I did not I
did not specify much uh much there um
and
that's that's basically it um you know
this this paper actually I'll go back
here
um what they've got
one remarkable quote in here I got it it
should also be noted oh so these are I I
think they're going to be British
authors and so when they say chip they
mean uh french fries
uh so it should also be noted these
estimated 154 G potato french fry
serving alahh contents so this is in a
small serving of french fries in the in
the typical oils that french fries are
being fried in 154 grams not a large
serving at all are not dissimilar to
those arising from the smoking of a
daily allocation of 25 tobacco
cigarettes I.E the alpab beta
unsaturated and saturated alahh coton
alahh and n hexanol respectively wow
from less than a normal serving of like
a McDonald's french
fry thing I don't know what units they
come in
but what do you call that thing envelope
well I said a small serving of serving I
don't know basket something also I'm
pretty sure obviously they say chips in
Britain but I'm pretty sure potato chip
always means potato chip no yeah in
Britain they call chips crisps no I know
that but if you say potato chip I think
that's if you read the rest of the paper
you'll see that they are consistent um
now it may be it may be that this one is
actually about chips but they've been
talking about
um they they've been talking a lot about
okay uh well yeah actually I'm not sure
in this case um so so can you go back to
the
graph this one uh or the the theirs
their version which is this I just added
some stuff yeah yeah either one okay
that's clearer I think uh can you show
it SEC so one
thing that is evident from this if we
try to extrapolate yeah from what
they've shown us to deep frying
yeah coconut oil and butter
Plateau yeah yeah you can actually you
can you can it looks like coconut oil
and butter I guess it's it an ASM toote
out
and so what that means is since the X
AIS is time yeah what we're saying is
that there's some level of these bad
things that is produced but it doesn't
just keep going up indefinitely with
more time it actually you know 40
minutes in and you've gotten almost all
the way there on butter and halfway
there on coconut oil um and the numbers
are tiny so I mean again the y axis on
coconut oil and butter is um half as
tall yep and if you look at the Corno
oil and the sunflower they do look like
they're headed ASM toote but the point
is uh a the absolute quantity has far
exceeded coconut oil and butter at the
100 minutes and it ain't stopping right
so what this implies is that there are a
certain number of
molecules that will be converted into
these toxic aldah and the time in which
you fry them
uh adjusts how far along that process
you are um and
so um from the point of view of either a
what they're calling shallow frying you
know if you're going to shallow fry
something in a
pan at 25 minutes in coconut oil or
butter you're at a tiny fraction of what
will ultimately be produced that is
harmful
um so this reflects even better on those
two things and if you were to put them
in a vat and do deep frying the absolute
quantity of these things will Top out in
butter and coconut oil early presumably
and so in both cases so I guess I guess
my point is how bad are these things for
you well if the alahh tides if are the
measure of how toxic these things are
which is which is the measure these guys
are using I have no no idea if that's
the right choice but they're not good
for it's a proxy maybe there's other
stuff that you could measure but it's a
proxy and short duration frying and
coconut oil or butter is actually uh the
tiniest fraction of what's going on in
corn oil and sunflow flow oil which are
of course the industrial standard
because they could be sourced in huge
quantities um they're not seasonal at
all and they're cheap right and so this
is a classic case where the uh uh the
shiny reputation of vegetable oils uh
has created who knows how much health
damage um and the thing you know the
things that have been demonized like
butter um were better for you all along
all along they were better for you all
along and so I mean these authors are
understandably I I I feel like I read in
In This Very stayed you know standard
academic Pros just like deep frustration
at having not been listened to for years
and years and years and uh and I
probably won't be able to find it here
but they say
um somewhere in
here they they talk about how despite
the research that they and others have
been presenting literally since the
1990s Health standards continue like
recommendations from from public health
organizations continue to recommend
unsaturated fats over saturated fats
yeah they they continue to say that and
you know okay heart.org which is the
official website of American Heart
Association at this point I expect that
and that's exactly what I found when I
went there but when I just tried doing a
I don't I'm trying to figure out what I
think random Google search pretending
you know not to be me not signed in as
me and everything um I could not find
anything that suggested that this wasn't
true right all of the standard like
Medline and like all of these standard
sites uh
that I maybe used to think that might be
a decent starting Place yeah are exactly
the wrong place to go ever well right
and so like really like the academic
literature is is full of garbage but if
you know how to read what you're reading
then you can at least find something
the I I believe that this is
actually um an impossible to imagine but
very clear prediction of the game theory
yeah in other words if you have a system
that is open
to financial
corruption how would that work in the
case of uh oils and fats and the
scientific literature well you would
have industry groups fostering the
production of results that favor their
product what force is it that is
supposed to
prevent your academic institutions from
concluding the upside down thing if it's
profitable for some industry that
understands they have to uh demonize the
healthy stuff and uh valorize the
dangerous stuff of course this would
happen so um what we live in is an
upside down World in which the experts
are always wrong because the whole point
is the experts are a threat to an
industry that would be profitable except
for their expertise so of course they've
re-engineered the system to spit out uh
exactly what they want spit out and
this this raises a question about
the we are told we are not supposed to
give medical advice because we're not
medical doctors right yep on the other
hand what happens if the medical doctors
are captured by a process that will
cause them to give you advice that's bad
for your health who is supposed to give
you advice to ignore your doctor if your
doctor has been captured by Pharma or by
Big A or uh by Monsanto or whatever
right so I'm not I'm not claiming to
know the answer to that question but I
am going to say it's a question because
again and again and again you're going
to damage your health listening to the
expert experts because you're told that
nobody is allowed to critique them and
um you know how many how many years of
margarin did the world suffer through
before it finally caught on to the fact
that it was terrible for you yeah and
um I don't
know I honestly do not know and probably
at this point the work will never be
done because again somehow we we won on
trans fats but canola oil versus
margarine I don't have any reason to
suspect that margarine is worse for you
than canola oil I'm sure that that is
like that is is that Mal information
because probably some branch of the
government assures you that trans fat is
bad for you and um and canola and
unsaturated fats are good for you and
therefore since I'm disagreeing with the
government I'm causing you to distrust
the government so that was probably Mal
information but I don't know and i' i'
I'd like to know actually um you know so
these these people could could do the
work like they could do that same work
and also add a v shortening or margarine
or something they're frying stuff in uh
and see what kind of alahh highes get
produced but of course alahh might be
the wrong you know it may be that trans
fats produce some other kind of
cytotoxic and genotoxic nastiness that
just isn't measurable by the same
proxies yeah we're uh living in a dark
age that has been created so that people
can continue to sell us stuff that's
terrible yep indeed but um pleased to
see this this piece of work grootveld
persal and grootveld 2018 all right uh
in in the hepatobilary surgery and
nutrition Journal which just tickles me
we used to get that one when I was a kid
we had that around uh around our house
it's uh it's not the most exciting
publication but it has its moments yeah
well here's one of them
right yes I would just like to point out
the margarine is not gone um yeah it's
still for sale well no no no not not
called margarine I'm sure you can buy
actual margarine but um on all of the
field trips and like group things that
I've been on uh through school and
everything there was always um vegan
butter as a thing that was around which
just sort of it's because lots of people
are including myself are allergic to
Darian so it just makes it easy if
that's what you bring um but having
looked at it recently it's exactly the
same stuff it's just it's marger and
it's shortening it's it's that um it's
apparently they're allowed to sell it as
yell but because brave men in Congress
they're on your side brave men in
Congress it's so now there's a different
rationale of course it's not that um
it's not the butter is bad for you it's
now that Dairy is like they've have they
have a different basically marketing way
to to get it into everyone's diets but
it's still certainly around yeah no and
I I mean margarine is actually for sale
as margarine as well still um but I do
actually I do think uh that the vegan
angle is one that presumably in the 50s
they didn't see coming but you know
they're going to convince a whole lot of
people who think it's um either immoral
or dangerous to to eat any animal
products and they're going to give them
toxic lab Sledge
instead
[Music]
toxic toxic lab sludge yeah but it's
yellow yeah yeah beautiful all right um
maybe that that gets us there it gets us
somewhere it gets us it gets us here it
gets us uh as far away from toxic lab
Sledge yellow or not as possible all
right yeah so we are going to take a
break and then we will come back for a
locals only Q&A join us there we're
going to start with a question from the
Discord server as we always do um but
then we'll be um actually looking at the
chat and um and just do a short Q&A see
how see how this goes see if this is how
we want to do q&as in the future so come
join us at locals please um we got lots
of benefits there and this is this is is
one of them
uh check out our stuff at Darkhorse
store.org we got scop until proven
otherwise blueberries because accidents
happen um
Goliath um uh lie to a tyrant it's good
our our younger son is wearing that
hoodie around actually you are too are
you both wearing that around yeah it's
very nice um both our sons are lying to
tyrants and hopefully not to
us right that would be yeah that just
indiscriminate lying is bad you limit
your lying to tyr absolutely um check
out Natural Selections um I piece this
week included um a small photo array
from my unfortunate recent forray into
Costco um which included Beauty sponges
brought to you by Hershey's and by peeps
what does that even mean I don't know
here actually I'm going to Zack I'm
going to you know you can you show it my
screen still this is just the sign up
hold on I got to find it um before I
plug in um um I'm plugged in but I'm not
I haven't found it yet I'm not plugged
in I'm clearly
incompetent okay hold
on um yeah so that's just that's the
picture I can you just um what but what
does it mean so they're do you know what
a beauty sponge is okay I don't really
either um but I believe that a beauty
sponge is um well it's it's
um it's like an open cell lab sludge
just to continue with the lab sludge is
this food no no this is not food this is
something that you can use to either um
to cake up your face or maybe even if
you put like some some soap or oil on it
to decake your face after you've walked
through the day with your face obscured
under a mat of artifice now I get it so
it's a beauty sponge yes which means
it's like it's a lab sludge artifice
sponge thing but it's brought to you by
Hershey's and peeps so the peeps Beauty
sponges kind of look like peeps I don't
know what Peeps are made of they're
grotesque unto themselves obviously but
it some of those sponges kind of look
like peeps right is there's a there's a
bunny and a chicken I think maybe but
the harshey ones what Vanessa what what
are those are those chocolate I mean
they're not they're sponges they're
Beauty sponges what is going on here
what is actually happening I do
Wonder what thought process I mean I'm
not saying it's wrong it may be that
people are mindlessly shopping and you
can trigger their hunger circuits by
showing them a familiar logo of a
chocolate bar and that causes them to I
I don't know I don't know either so most
people will be familiar with Costco um
and I hadn't been in one thankfully in a
long time but so these were in the uh
the what's the section with all the
drugs like the it's like it's the drug
store well it's the drug but they're not
but there's like a pharmacy and then
there's a section that you can just walk
through so I just decided this time
because it was grotesque outside and I
was I had time to kill I was like you
know what I'm going to do this like an
anthropologist I'm going to walk down
every single aisle in the Costco which I
think I've never done before so this was
in that section like in between like the
pyc and the I don't even know what
there's so many crazy things in that
store um so there wasn't any other food
around which may go to your
hypothesis that uh that wandering
through uh you know shampoo and
and I don't even know I it's it's so
dystopian every everything like I I did
find myself at least in the fancy cheese
aisle for a while going like yes this is
real food I like this yeah I mean one do
not want to demonize Costco specifically
because Costco is uh is better than most
of these things things they're actually
Humane to their employees a labor
perspective as well uh and they you know
some of the products are higher quality
than you would find at competing uh big
box stores and they've got re I mean the
cheese is a good example right they've
got they've got ex some excellent cheese
that said it does
still I can't go into one of these
places and not think Earth Liquidation
Center absolutely yeah yep yep yep and
uh in fact I wrote about this little bit
this week on natural sexs as well I
again I still had some time uh and it
was gross I was like okay I'm going to
I'm just going to continue to do it I'm
going to go into some places that I
don't normally go into and I was like
there's a there's like a RW Stress For
Less I'm not even sure if I've ever been
in one of those before there's a Bed
Bath and Beyond and I got close like the
Bed Bath and Beyond has literally been
liquidated um like this it was just
empty totally empty like I don't know if
they're moving in or moving out or what
but the
Ross half the shelves were empty so it's
liquidating Earth at the the same time
that things are becoming unavailable
even crap even stuff that you shouldn't
want to have available do you remember
how Earth used to be when it was better
um I do um okay as long I know we're
signing off here but I've got sorry I've
got one more thing to show um this this
was from the Ross dressed for Less um I
did not rearrange anything I swear to
you just like most of the shells are
empty and there was one sad lawn
flamingo with a Ross Tag on his neck and
a fire extinguisher sign in the
background in case I don't know why you
would need to extinguish a fire in the
store at this point there's nothing to
save and a bunch of rolled up cheap
carpet
like this is 2024 welcome to it yeah
it's going to get weirder yeah it's
going to get weirder so um do join us on
locals in 15 minutes or so for our Q&A
and uh and
and yeah we appreciate you uh
subscribing to rumble and locals and
joining us there and sharing what you
like and um liking what you share and
well liking hitting the like button
right and um and we will we oh I forgot
to say we will actually be back on
Saturday uh so we're going to be back
sooner this time rather than rather than
later so we are going to come back to
you on Saturday at new normal time 11:30
but our old regular day on Saturday um
so if you can't make it to the Q&A
that's about to happen join us here
again in four short days four three
short days can't even do week math now
um and until we see you next time be
good to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside be well
[Music]
everyone